chèrement j'ai préféré sa modestie et sa
bonté et m'a plu plein de choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au début mes parents on voulait pas trop
parce que il ne connaissait pas encore
l'expérience d'anciens après m'en
laisser avant tout revanche j'avais plus
de deux mois de cours pendant les
grandes vacances a logé un mois de
vacances demain pour rattraper et
devancer les autres parce qu'on tournait
dans une période scolaire ou à l'état
ceinture y en a pas c'est une béquille
tour des seniors
si t'as pas le cas d'un acteur qui
retourna c'est assez fou pour gagner
pour la première fois et il va tomber
sur un homme qui fait 300 km pour aller
voir son idole
nous sommes et comment tu vas rentrer je
sais pas mais cet homme s'appelle
comment t'as vu le déjà au moins 7 à 11
ans m en amenant le petit va reconnecter
avec le son passé ses racines et il va
lier un lien avec les six
ils sont tous croyants et donc c'est ce
qu'a le sénégal de particuliers et donc
c'est ça qu'on voulait aussi raconter
parce que c'est ça le sénégal des
mariages qui se font entre chrétiens
musulmans et que et que et qu' ils
cohabiter qui font toutes les fêtes
forcément mais c'est c'est là où je dis
que c'est ce qui importe ici c'est la
croyance les gens se cohabitent sont
ceux jugés ou questionner notre croyance
c'est juste parce que c'est la
spiritualité qu'un pas parce que
justement alors la spiritualité passe
avant la religion que le chemin des
ancêtres continuer à guider tepa
c'est la terre de ses ancêtres tout doit
y aller
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voulait absolument vous le montrer
voilà vous avez fait un super cadeau
nous accueillons comme vous l'avez fait
la dernière fois pour le tournage et
aujourd'hui encore
donc merci pour tout ça et voilà nous
c'est ça notre cadeau habitants qui sont
là nous ont très bien accueillis
accueilli les camions toute l'équipe
il était avec nous tout en pas donc au
monde onuci se demander ce qu'on faisait
c'est bizarre quand tu sais pas ce que
font les gens ne manqueront on leur a
promis de venir leur montrer leur
expliquer pourquoi les a dérangés